eric clapton yeah hooked up rumor has it
they hooked up you damn right you know
what you know his nickname is right you
know what isn't it you know what Eric
Clapton's nickname I sure do
fingers clapped in closed Slowhand
yes that's a great it is was a caracal
Adam first celebrity I ever saw when I
was in New York City I was trying to be
an actor and I went to this really cool
underground club I belong I didn't
belong there and it's where you see
these when I was a young man 21 22 I saw
these women that were thrown and I saw
Eric Clapton there with this beautiful
woman and I was like it's like looking
at like you're a young man and it's like
seeing your first line at the zoo holy
place reasoning right there that's Eric
Clapton like that's you know they call
me and even deal you know what they call
me what it's not I didn't give myself
long calm the mailman what's happening
man that you deliver I deliver mmm
through the back male men don't deliver
through the back though I understand
no I'm like ups I'll drop it off in the
back yeah I see I don't think that's a
good nickname is you have to explain
that you're no mailman so you take you
coming through the [ __ ] doggy style or
what does that mean her or you go to the
back pale man you going to dropping the
boxes off you going into South bad the
terrible metaphor man I'm just slow hand
is slow hand by I'm slow hand you know
I'm saying all right all right you don't
like the mailman that man doesn't really
ring it's not gonna stick you know I'm
saying brother you don't think what
you're part of like oh [ __ ] there's the
mailman yeah I called the mailman Mac
cuz he drops everything through the bag
but cuz they go well mail men usually
drop things in the front I don't that's
right I know but he's like it's like
what can big brown do for you and he
drops in the bag you know my buddy is
Joe Jana Moore who who are very wealthy
buddy he's the worst with metaphors the
worst of metaphors you know you gotta
shoot for the stars cuz you've missed
the stars but you might just end up
dropping on a cloud I'm like have you
ever had any Girl Scout cookies ever
what you say I know I don't think I've
ever had him how are you been America 38
37 years headon he never had a Girl
Scout know why I don't know why I've
never had any it's weird I'm so
disappointed in you right now you've
never had what I'll bring the box
tomorrow okay but Bri I'll bring one of
the roles of the Thin Mints they have
you never had tag ones I've been other
ones any of them all right so start
Monday off huh god you're you're Isis I
don't want Girl Scout cookie I think I
was ever offered I guess I have to go
out buy it first hey man they're
everywhere you can't shake these little
girls trying to slang cookies I always
want positive The Grove that's in
whoever the mom I don't know if they
have to you have licenses or what or or
some sort of permit but she was in the
Grove just so hanging cookies by the
Train of the the Grove the train goes
round shoes where everyone gets off the
train my son loves the Train I get off
on like well what do you have here and
then my girls all know and well I gotta
help the kids out like I will take eight
boxes she's all eight I'm like totally
kids out
I got four Tagalongs those are my
favorite to thin mints and to Samoas
I'll bring something tomorrow
god damn it chin I know there's rumors
again that Tito Ortiz and Chuck Liddell
would rematch a part three all right so
Ortiz is saying stuff like he would come
out of retirement for that fight and
Chuck is saying like he would actually
take that fight and but this article in
particular was interesting cuz it says
Chuck would be shocked if he wasn't
cleared for a return and his I shouldn't
laugh though
but and his reasoning is because he's
had tests done for mountain climbing you
can see her here I had medical exams for
mountain climbing and I cleared
everything there so I should be just
fine well he says I don't know why I
wouldn't be cleared I have medical exams
for my mountain climbing yeah a little
mount climbing fighting is a little
different though Chuck and I cleared
everything so I'd be just fine well
we'll have to see if they don't clear me
I'd be shocked they've cleared a lot of
people in La Salette shape
than I am so it's not about your
physical shape it's about the damage of
mental health yeah yeah it's it's about
the where's your brain out where's your
cerebral skills at where's your speech
at and I would say that there's some
signs of speech impediment from you and
punched in the face with Chuck Liddell
not that he couldn't still compete he
probably can do I want to see it know am
i wanted to judge nope is there a place
for this yes is there a fanbase for this
yes
is there a masters league in this would
be you know masters League kind of fight
like people to tune in you know it
reached over a million not pay-per-views
but as far as spectators what do I want
see it no not at all no not in the least
bit I wish guys retire and find someone
of their other passions and make tons of
money that's what I wish would happen
but that's not the way this works a
Scott Coker had something to say about
it as well so the thing is this is sort
of like clickbait ish the title it says
Scott Coker unsure if Bellator would be
able to promote Chuck Liddell vs. Tito
Ortiz 3 okay but he's saying that just
because you know the contract stuff with
UFC because Chuck might still be under
contract with UFC like a freeze contract
when he left
yeah what do you see they do some shady
[ __ ] so the one of the reasons or
they're one of the best organizations
they have the best flourish so when you
retire which I did
you're not released of your contract you
contract this frozen so he can't go
anywhere else did we decide to come back
it has to be in the UFC however was
Chuck see how that works
I'll assume Dana would kind of let me do
his thing I don't think Dan's gonna hold
truck to anything he said that he
wouldn't let him do it obviously in the
UFC cuz he cares about it to me she
recently said that did I wonder what he
would he let him I you know they're
friends I think they're still close I
don't know what do I wish Danny would go
just for his health we go nuts or not
releasing yeah that's what I mean yeah
it's time in the UFC for spout or thing
it's just as a friend thing I don't want
so you get her but you don't need any
more punishment you're showing some
signs we don't we don't need that but I
don't think if if let's say Chuck for
whatever reason it needed to fight I
don't think Dan would hold them to it I
don't think about that do you think man
I have four hundred eighty million
dollars in the bank I don't give a
flying [ __ ] what anyone does that's how
I would act but I don't know renovating
the bathroom great fans
steam shower hold on heated toilets a
day in a dryer like a nice you want to
clean your Rampal process hold on let me
peur whistle Connie talk about bidet
real quick Bryan Callen will make
whatever sink he finds in a restaurant
for taking [ __ ] a bidet no wow you won't
feel the brian brian at comedy clubs
will get on the water splashes ass what
are you doing he goes gotta clean your
whistle man yo that's not a bidet
we wash our hands and just take the
water you really do that because there's
no there's no you do that but if it's a
party what are you [ __ ] chris kattan
you don't do so much no no you go Pat
well my ass clean and I'll taste like I
was at that you were math is not my
thing I want to squirt a freaking stream
up my ass I was at the [ __ ] cloud was
a nice clean walk I was in a comedy club
I took a [ __ ] and I jumped up on the
sink I know I've seen that I began to
wash my oh no I wouldn't do it in a
restaurant cuz that's something what
does the way just say I I was up with my
this thing I'll embarrass you miss it I
asked my [ __ ]
it's already terrible it's already kind
of like a secret right second of it well
she comes in she walks in and people are
leaving so as they're walking out my
fans can see that I hit him with a frog
she opened the door saw me and she was
whatever day you and she looked at me
and closed the door immediately and I
jumped off and I never spoke about it
and I've been
she never spoke about it either I highly
doubt she told everybody hey I would I
caught Ryan basically [ __ ] in the
same washing okay I'm trying to push it
down like he's making french fries out
of potatoes I wipe it very well I just
make sure that it's very my whistles
cleaned so dry don't [ __ ] in the sink
hey you know what you are you were the
kid when you're taking a piss in
elementary you put your pants all the
way down I don't want a dirty I can't
have [ __ ] on my yeah I knew I was like
that so stratum is Aaron of course
there's always one